tu as lu c'est la fin de ces 32 vidéo on
s'est fait une énigme par jour pendant
32 jours à l'intérieur du défi une vidéo
par jour pendant un an
dernière vidéo dernière énigme je
commence par vous donner de la réponse
de l'énigme d'hier et à la fin de la
vidéo après là où trop je vous mettrais
la réponse de l'énigme d'aujourd'hui et
à partir de demain donc on reprend la
chaîne avec le format normal
une vidéo par jour pendant un an avec le
calendrier normal que vous trouvez dans
le descriptif
j'ai fait ces vidéos donc en avance je
voulais dire ou youtube se paye je vous
ferai voir la toute fin de la vidéo je
prendrai un petit peu quelques plans du
plateau ça veut dire que là dans le vrai
rythme de diffusion des vidéos moi ça
fait quelques jours que j'ai attaqué
pour vous préparer les nouvelles vidéos
bref réponse à l'énigme d'hier si vous
n'avez pas vu penser à aller la voir
tout de suite répond c'est que pierre
n'a pas de voiture du tout et n'ont pas
de voiture alors comment on sait qu'il
n'a pas de voiture pour quoi et bien on
va prendre des exemples si le premier et
non c'est vrai alors le dernier l'est
aussi
et comme on sait que deux énoncés ne
peut pas être vrai on est obligé
d'éliminer le premier et le troisième
directement mais si le deuxième est vrai
ça voudrait dire que le troisième est
vrai aussi
donc le nombre de voitures et forcément
0 ça ne fonctionne vraiment qu'avec zéro
voiture oui je sais que dans les
commentaires vous à dire c'est quoi
cette embrouille
et il fallait bien que vous embrouiller
un petit peu sur au moins à l'avant
dernière vidéo mais en tout cas ça
fonctionne en toute logique mais en
parlant de logique
l'énigme d'aujourd'hui les beaucoup plus
cette série de vidéos je vous l'avais
annoncé je la fais ou youtube space
merci d'ailleurs pour le décor le
matériel et tout le soutien qu'ils me
donnent ça me permettait de choses de
faire cette série de vidéos ça me
permettait déjà moi de vous faire un
petit break pour cet été est de pouvoir
écrire davantage de contenu pour la
rentrée donc ce que j'appelle la rentrée
c'est à partir de demain cet été
forcément je le sais je vais pas prendre
le temps de répondre exactement à tous
les commentaires comme je fais
habituellement je vais tous les lire
c'est sûr mais pas forcément y répondre
à partir des vidéos demain par contre
comme d'habitude je reprendrai le temps
en fin de semaine de répondre à tous les
commentaires de la semaine qu'auront été
me donne donc la dernière énigme et je
vous donnerai la solution après l'as
outreau de cette vidéo là cette boule ou
sept balles ont une apparence
complètement identique la même forme la
même taille la même couleur mais l'une
des sept boules légèrement mais les
charmants à quelques grammes près plus
légère que les autres à l'aide d'une
balance à plateaux
vous savez les balances où il ya un
plateau de chaque côté et si on met
quelque chose de plus lourd ici ça fait
ça ou ça comment déterminer en 2 peser
seulement qu'elle est la boule la plus
hier je vous laisse réfléchir à ça la
solution elle est après les autres au
vous n'êtes pas obligé de la regarder
aujourd'hui vous pouvez attendre jusqu'à
demain par exemple pour vous laisser 24
heures pour trouver la solution
je suis ravi qu'on reprenne le rythme
habituel demain pour la dernière ligne
droite du défi d'une vidéo par jour
pensez à vous abonner si ce n'est pas
déjà fait et rendez vous demain à 17h
ciao
la réponse c'est que en 2 pesé vous
allez commencer par peser 3 boules de
chaque côté si c'est exactement
équilibré si les deux plateaux sont
équilibrés ça veut dire que la boule la
plus légère c'est celle qui reste là
celle ci elle est invisible
sinon si le plateau bascule vous mettez
de côté les trois balles les plus
lourdes puisque vous avec la légère et
du côté du plateau qui a monté en fait
quel prix les jeux puis avec les trois
qui vous reste eh bien on fait comme
pour la première pesée vous en regardez
une devant vous et vous en mettez une de
chaque côté du plateau
si le plateau ne bouge pas exactement
identique ça veut dire que la plus
légère c'est celle que vous n'avez pas
mise si le plateau baisse comme ça c'est
à dire que la plus légère celle celle ci
et si c'est comme ça c'est que c'est
celle là mais je pense l'onac et avait
trouvé ça on verra aussi au nombre de
ratios de deux pouces en l'air quel
était le nombre de personnes qui avaient
trouvé la bonne réponse voulait dire
merci évidemment toute l'équipe du
youtube space paris qui m'a aidé à faire
ces vidéos par rapport aux décors aux
changements des corps je vous faire voir
un tout petit peu le plateau avez vous
fait voir s'ils décrochent d'ici je vous
emmène avec moi donc voici ce que vous
ne voyez pas alors oui évidemment
c'était c'était bien bien faux fond
c'était une fausse nuit tout ça a été
complètement fake ici c'était un décor
en fait un petit peu l'offt et et jeu là
c'est tout ce que je pouvais et claire
également utilisé pour pour transformer
pour transformer un petit peu ce décor
là j'ai hâte de vous retrouver demain
dans le format normal en tout cas merci
merci à vous d'avoir suivi ces 32 vidéo
merci de suivre le mental blog qui je
vous rappel est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an
n'oubliez pas de laisser le fameux
poussant lettres laisser un petit quand
je prendrai le temps d'y répondre c'est
bon maintenant à partir de la fin de
semaine je réponds à tous les comme
comme avant est en tout cas je vous
aurez lu tout l'été ça je peux vous le
promettre
n'oubliez pas également de vous abonner
avant de partir c'est très important et
rendez vous demain à 17h ciao